vous voyez maintenant dans une étape de
ma vie
l avantage de parler comme ça en dernier
c'est que on va pouvoir prendre appui
sur des tas de choses qui ont déjà été
dit le pasteur qui vient avec ses trucs
d'électricien et puis j'ai eu des
histoires avec des pasteurs qui étaient
mes clients voilà les pays qui eux au
niçois qui mal y pense
g j'ai entendu les filles qui a enchanté
become bouillot a fait des choses comme
ça mon histoire quand on parle rebonds
c'est ma vie a été une succession de
deux rebonds vraiment de choses assez
particulière et la première chose que
j'ai fait de ma vie quand j'étais en
classe de maturité dire je n'ai pas du
tout envie de de travailler en usine
pour financer mes études
et puis je vais faire un permis poids
lourds tout le monde est parti en voyage
de maturité - j'étais en classe 2 enfin
avec des avec des chauffeurs pour
apprendre à conduire poids lourds et
c'était une aventure extraordinaire
budget du m'engager pour trois étés à la
brasserie où j'ai où j'ai appris et puis
c'était quelque chose vous voyez
maintenant ici comme ça mais c'était
c'est un boulot infiniment maintenant
porter des caisses de bière conduire le
camion et biz a fini avec des camions
toujours plus gros avait des camions la
3 essieux avec une benne 18 tonnes et
puis tu regardes eu autant machin tu dis
ouais tu veux que je te pose ça ou là le
sable ou le tout venant
et puis ce après sa cure tout temps
machin
c'est avéré c'est lui c'est une espèce
de satisfaction un peu anale non de
laisser cela derrière le c7 immostat
derrière toi tu avances et puis les
petits vallat
bon alors mais que j'étais à la fois ce
midi dans un camion il disait mais
est-ce que je suis bien dans ma peau
non non je ne fais pas bien dans ma peau
mais il faut beaucoup de temps pour pour
faire un chemin où tu changes ton
identité là l'identité la plus solide
qu'on a dans la vie c'est l'identité de
genre d'un mec août et une nana et puis
c'est sacré donc malgré que je lisais
déjà les histoires de d'un journaliste
anglais qui était le premier journaliste
anglais a grimpé sur le reste j'ai dit
oui il y en a qui le font mais moi je
n'avais pas le courage j'ai vous
m'appelez mouthe mais le courage au
début de carrière et il n'était pas trop
là mais par contre on a commencé à faire
des choses qu'est ce que je dois faire
ici boxer à prendre le taureau par les
cornes ouais d'accord ok alors le
deuxième chose c'est que les histoires
de chantier était fini une fille dit
tiens qu'est-ce qu'on fait ce qu'on peut
faire de d'amusant dans la vie alors
lieu un peu d'argent et tout ça donc
bosser alors j'ai acheté cet autocar et
avec ça j'ai fondé une coopérative à
genève qui faisait du transport d'abord
de d'élèves
et puis justement après pasteur et ça
c'était une entrée dans la vie qui était
assez amusante parce que
tout d'un coup un d un de mes amis m'a
demandé mes papiers dont les voyages
est ce que tu pourrais pas aussi nous
trouver des tickets bon marché on
parlait à l'époque c'était le mot
c'était marché gris donc je parle des
années 70 ça vous permettra de deviner
mon âge alors je disais oui bien sûr on
va chercher ça je dois vous avouer qu'à
l'époque que j'ai dit oui on va faire ça
je ne connaissais pas la signification
de l'acronyme l'iata international air
transport association
j'imaginais que ça peut éventuellement
être une marque de dentifrice ou quelque
chose comme ça mais je ne connaissais
pas mais aussi émis donc l'histoire les
rebonds je crois c'est aussi toujours
d'avoir le courage de dire je m'en fous
ce qui est professionnel je m'en fous de
ce que de ce que sap les autres je m'en
fiche si les autres sont beaucoup
meilleur
on essaye et puis on regarde ce que ça
donne bon c'est entrer dans la vie elle
était extrêmement amusante donc c'était
l'époque des communautés des entreprises
autogérées des de toute une série de
choses
il en reste encore aujourd'hui cette
entreprise est simple l apn donc voyage
à pn vous pouvez encore acheter vos
billets jésus aujourd'hui ils font du
tailgate chez gowlings today
et puis il y avait la librairie du
boulevard pour ceux qui sont genevois ou
qui ont travaillé à genève et qu'il
connaisse a donc toute une série de
coopérative de communautés dont vous
souhaitez c'est le sillage post 68
voilà mes de ma sensibilité
vous connaissez il ya une chose qui est
restée une fascination pour le business
et puis une deuxième chose une
fascination pour les soft facteurs alors
ça j'avais bien compris
une leçon à travers montée des
entreprises
si tu n'as pas les coeurs et les gens
les coeurs des gens et les gens de ton
côté tu vas de nulle part
donc ça c'était quelque chose qui a
ensuite ça qui m'a permis d'aller plus
loin donc et qui m'a ouvert la porte
pour une carrière pour une carrière
académique j'ai tout simplement arrêter
tout ça mais cela le rebond était je
suis tombé malade moi comment un
chapitre de ma vie se termine je tombe
malade et je tombe malade de ac voilà
violemment donc je ne bouge plus donc
pour quitter les autocars et tout ça je
suis tombé malade je ne pouvais plus
bouger je ne pourrais plus me lever
voilà donc je suis à sept est grave cave
épuisement nerveux ou quelque chose
comme ça et et puis quand je suis arrivé
à avoir un certain succès dans ma
carrière académique disons mais vu un
peu un peu hors normes
voilà c'est ça plus un certain nombre de
gens et on m'a fait la place et ça a eu
du succès on m'a toujours dit on m'a
toujours dit un certain moment à partir
de maintenant tu as fait une place mais
la seule chose qui peut te sauver celle
succès alors le succès il a été au
rendez vous j'ai même jeu aperçu
quelqu'un ici parmi parmi mes mes
anciens étudiants sur le thème de la
complexité mais un certain moment je
suis retombé malades et là c'était
carrément après avoir eu beaucoup de
succès la dernière à la dernière volée
de monde me demande
de mon master d'études je balance la
porte et puis on va tous on avait écouté
un psychanalyste y ont bien on était
tous rechargée à bloc et au moment où je
balance ouvre à mme laporte le plafond
se décrochent au dessus de moi j'étais
donc j'ai une commotion cérébrale il ya
toute ma colonne vertébrale qui s'ébroue
mise mise en compote et les autres et
elle a consterné
et puis - g j'ai encore pu rentrer mais
ensuite ça j'ai été j'étais malade et
puis ça a été le démarrage d'une wave de
mal être d'un malaise d'une maladie et
qui m'a coincé le dos au point que j'ai
dur et j'ai dû rester cinq mois
couché donc juillet 2007 à septembre à
décembre 2007 coucher et vous voyez ça
c'était c'était le produit avant sa
sphère produits actuels de ce type de
robot et c'était un petit peu le stress
tests aussi pour mille et pour mes
théories donc quand on dit ce soit qui
tu es bon bain soit qui tu es mais c'est
quoi à l'intérieur de toi est ce que tu
as envie de dire mais en réalité je suis
une petite fiche conduit des gros
camions mais en réalité je suis une
petite fille non ça ça ça joue pas donc
un certain moment ben qu'est-ce que j'ai
dû faire c'est chaque fois que je disais
je je change je fais le pas je quitte
mon passé et j'entre dans quelque chose
de nouveau
j'en ai mieux et chaque fois je dis faut
pas aller jusqu'aux dernières extrémités
rechute donc je pouvais me levais
peut-être une demi-heure ou une heure ou
quelque chose comme ça 8 allée faire les
commissions et puis où manger où faire
quelque chose à manger etc et aussi te
sa couche est nouveau ça a été l'horreur
j'ai passé un moment pendant cette
période là je dis là je vais bientôt
téléphoné à exceet parce que entre la
douleur est elle mal être les nausées et
tout ça je ne supporte plus et poussé
rebonds le jour où j'y dis bon j'ai
compris je dois faire le pas et
maintenant après 3 après trois chutes
jeudi
maintenant ce véhicule là il a des
marches avant mais il a pas de marche
arrière donc les histoires camion je
connais très bien ils ont toujours eu au
moins deux marches arrière mais il dit
là il ya plus de marche arrière
maintenant et à partir de ce moment là
trois jours plus tard on m'a appelé à
zurich parce que j'avais encore la
présidence d'une organisation
industrielle a dit écoute ton nouveau
truc sur la production climatiquement
neutre salle du succès maintenant il
faut se mettre devant les gens et tu
dois parler en public tu dois parler au
peuple est etc
jeudi mais tu sais que je suis malade il
dit combien tu as d'autonomie g10 2h
2h30
mais ça suffit pour venir jusqu'à zurich
bon il ya une limousine qui t'attend à
la gare on amène à l'hôtel combien
d'heures tu dois rester couché pour être
de nouveau en état de nuire
j'ai dit au moins 4 5 heures est ok
alors tu viens suffisamment tôt on
t'emmène à l'hôtel il ya la limousine
qui t'attend j'ai fait mon truc j'ai
serré les mains
la voiture attendait un truc qui
normalement je le faisais à une demi
journée
ça m'a pris deux jours et demi mais je
les fais à partir de ce moment là j'ai
guéri mais j'avais pris une décision et
ça c est ce assez
je crois c'est la décision la plus dure
que j'ai prise de mad mabille
quand on va de l'avant la chose
principale c'est si vous faites vraiment
quelque chose qui peut décontenancer les
autres communiqué alors ça c'est quelque
chose de fondamental j'ai eu un ami qui
m'a dit écoute la communauté tu fais un
truc comme ça
la communication c'est fondamental alors
j'ai fait un plan de communication je
savais exactement à qui concilie je
faisais ça comment ça se passerait il y
aurait montant de de préparation il y
aurait le temps de la chirurgie elle
tendrait à paraître en public pas tout
de suite dans ces nouveaux danser nous
dans cette nouvelle identité donc j'ai
fait encore quelques mois mais qui
jusqu'à ce que je me sentais plus
suffisamment à l'aise mais j'ai
communiqué beaucoup et j'ai surtout eu
mes différents servent qu'une premier
sac c'était mes étudiants deuxième
certes mais professeur donc le premier
set c'était mes études à mes professeurs
deuxième cercle c'était c'était l'école
le troisième cercle c'était les
partenaires d'affaires avec lesquels on
faisait des projets
des choses comme ça ce que je voudrais
vous dire c'est qu'on vous rebondissez
content qu'autant les une histoire comme
ça et c'était c'était pas la première
mais heureusement que j'ai eu d'autres
beaux avant qu'ils ont été qui ont été
pas très facile mais que tu rebondis tu
ne rebondit pas que pour toi tout le
monde te vois et tu rebondis aussi pour
les autres et ça peut-être c'est la
chose la plus merveilleuse qu'on peut
faire randy by you you c'est la chose
qui j'ai complètement oublié une chose
maintenant je voulais encore parler
l'allemand mais bon parce que voyez de
sa pièce marie allons assister les
nazisme pour gagner l'un des 20 de canal
du canal mais ne mentionnait la qualité
n'y est stone india manhattan vos
nombreuses mises à l'eau habib minchin
et nyatchou fornasari stupide restée
coup de foudre ait des nomades mais dans
des salles est rhône alpes somme le
bâtiment jeunes ne savent à temps ou de
lieu d' iceman fondateur évident que
c'est un acteur comme time out à
boufarik eisenach riche oublions d'un ex
mountakha butte à une faute ramassage
adhésifs des armateurs météo
pensionnaires ont ce qui te vie va être
à bord en hausse une dizaine de gosses
qualité d'image bling ippj tanker d'ascq
store puis ta saltzman à monza offrir a
dit bigras de carrière peines courtes
comme une femme parole n'était pas en
retard
ayad listeria radio d'aspic city
artistique et fouillé mardi en coupe
d'espagne au classement genk a offert
aux dérives michel pinard médecine pas
deux pareils et une si bonne mitaine
mais tant qu'athée catéchisme the hunter
est suivi en tant que fan du design
steve harvey gagnent nos forces en
commun de petrus jacques fortin hamdan
choc computer naturel chic chick chick
teambooster da il dit au bois stage vovo
meet me in store hundsbach états unis
faro il ya je vais stone à wall street
chauffeur en tête d'habitant est un
dealer qui nous habite